there's no way to introduce this next
story other than simply to tell you what
happened which is that Donald Trump
congratulated Poland on the 80th
anniversary of World War two
of course the Holocaust sort of started
with Germany's invasion of Poland it's
not exactly something to be
congratulating them about other leaders
sent messages of somber remembrance and
reflection some even warning about
sliding back towards the type of
authoritarianism that we saw early in
the third Nazi Reich but Trump
congratulate SPO hland for having been
invaded by Germany 80 years ago take a
look at this we have Mike Pence our Vice
President is just about landing right
now and he is representing me I look
forward to being there soon but I just
want to congratulate Poland it's a great
country with great people we also have
many Polish people in our country it
could be 8 million we love our Polish
friends and I will be there soon there
is no question I mean the analysis here
is very simple
Trump has no idea what Poland's role was
in World War two he just had no idea
what the historical context was so he
said I congratulate them I mean just he
just doesn't know anything that's it
Trump was going to go to Poland for the
world war two remembrance he canceled
the trip because of Hurricane Dorian so
he was asked instead for a message on
this anniversary of a very very dark day
for Poland back in 1939 and his message
was congratulations what was possibly
the darkest day in Polish history and
Donald Trump congratulate s' them this
is indistinguishable from satire if I
said to someone what's the worst
possible thing you could say to Poland
on the 80th anniversary of being raped
and pillaged by the Nazis
congratulations would be pretty high on
the list he does not know what happened
in World War two period Poland lost 1/5
of its population during World War 2 a
much bigger percentage of the Jew
population was lost in Poland during
World War two congratulations guys a
message of congratulations this is not
very different than congratulating
Israel on Holocaust Remembrance Day
I mean it's absolute and total idiocy
the the only other possibility I can
think of and tell me what you think
about this trump saying this happened
because he doesn't know what happened to
Poland in World War two is one
explanation there's a more sinister one
though which is that Trump knows Germany
invaded Poland in World War two and he
likes it I don't actually think that
that's what's going on here I don't I
try not to attribute to malice what can
be more than adequately explained by
stupidity and ignorance and in this case
Trump has shown and demonstrated over
the last many years no knowledge of
history whatsoever and so I would
attribute this to ignorance and not
malice we're only a few days from the
9/11 anniversary
what is Donald Trump liable to say then
not good not good make sure you're
following me on Instagram at David
Pakman and while you are there follow
the show on instagram at david pakman
show we will take a quick break our long
form deep dive into the regulation of
social media is coming up next really
really important topic and then much
more coming up after that